the US Navy is nearing the end of a
first-of-its-kind training mission for
more than a week about 300 French Navy
members have been living and training on
an American aircraft carrier the USS
George HW Bush off the East Coast Jan
Crawford went on board and joins us from
Naval Station Norfolk in Virginia Jan
good morning
well we're on the deck of the USS Gerald
R Ford but out at sea on the bush is
where these training exercises are just
wrapping up it marked the first time the
US and French pilots mechanics and
sailors have lived together side-by-side
on an aircraft carrier and we were there
to see how this mission all came
together we reached the USS George HW
Bush like the Navy does from the sky
going from 150 miles an hour to a dead
stop in less than two seconds on another
busy day of flight operations the
mission joint training exercises with a
key ally France what's it like being
here on the USS George HW Bush of course
your carriers are so huge right and big
it is holding upwards of 5,000 people
the carrier has everything you would
need cafeterias a store gyms a post
office and a chapel Rear Admiral Stephen
Evans commands that George HW Bush and
all the ship personnel in its Carrier
Strike Group everyday I'm an artist I
mean you think about what goes into this
this is a city a city with an airfield
on top of it the lifeblood that goes
through it are these young men and women
for the French visitors it's a chance to
sharpen their skills with the best while
working on a runway moving through the
ocean at more than 30 miles an hour this
experience is awesome right yeah it's a
kind of Brotherhood we do the same job
we did many operations together with
everyone performing key roles in the
ship's tower the air officer or air boss
controlling the airspace on the flight
deck the landing signal officers
communicating with pilots as they come
in for landing touching down at the
right moment so a
on the tail of the plane snags a wire
across the flight deck this is what
catches the aircraft this engineering
marvel is programmed below deck or the
ship's hydraulic systems slow the plane
down with takeoffs and landings
happening at the same time day and night
it feels like organized chaos and
keeping it all organized is the aircraft
handling officer this is a reason for a
Ouija board yes this is what it picks
what's going on on the flight deck
Lieutenant Commander Winston Cottle is
the ship's handler there are computers
that do this too this one does it frees
up that one would freeze up in time and
sometimes electronic will be going down
and shut off and I don't have time to
mess with that and overseeing all these
operations is the ship's captain Sean
Bailey how is this helping us in our
readiness it's important from the
perspective of demonstrating support for
our allies at the same time it sends a
signal to the world that we're strong
partners hand-in-hand
now the US has 11 aircraft carriers that
is more than any other nation the French
only have one the Charles de Gaulle it's
now undergoing extensive maintenance so
while that's taking place training
exercises like this one really help our
allies like the French stay prepared and
ready for anything
John Jan thanks organized chaos that's
what she said that boy it is amazing
always an engineering marvel to know how
they do that but it's good we're helping
out the French - yes exactly
while city on sea